BS it into the Zone there's to Smith up past
him to the near side chipped ahead by besser
and he'll feed it up to Miller Dei in front
Miller with a shot muster makes a save just
15 seconds in and watch besser along the
boards this a beautiful little chip pass
right to JT Miller Miller with 10 goals in
the season you know there's a good chance
he's going to shoot that's a good first sa
he's been flying a late with po pil and Zer
the rookies with him cadri feeds it here's it
out the shoulder of the Smith and that rims the
glass and winds up going out of play and a good
look for number 16 as the Flames look for the
opening goal he really challenges he knows
he's that's his guy doesn't go down on his
knees Miller that pass tipped across heroic
there Chucks it down low besser able to get
it plays it to The Far Side they'll get
it set up now Point Hughes feeds it over
Miller Qui pass Pon scores beautiful set
up in a onetime by Pon makes it one nothing
Vancouver very similar to the Miller goal last
night on the power play and he just watched this
movement right here it's going to come back
to Hughes quickly to Miller and in one quick
motion right over to peton and before marom can
even read the play or react there's an open net
for Pon one- nothing for the Canucks beautiful
Puck moving power play there's a allone patter
shot High left untouched in front and a great look
for a second gets another shot and markson's able
to steer that aside wow was that a great save
in behind you and that's what happens Noah Noah
hanifen doesn't spot him Pon with a great chance
he shoots wide but watch this little steal right
off the Stick of huberto popped away from RKA
and dppi with the dump in the other way there's
weager around for duet nice little play off the
boards and Away goes linle with Greer Lyle Greer
weager scores terrific goal by the Flames
defenseman and it's all CAU up [Applause]
one the defense's going to pinch in right
there and he just chips a puck by him right
to lyol now nice passing here lyol to Greer
and with weager also joining the rush he gets
that beautiful shot off short side beating to
Smith but this play does not happen unless du
makes that great play and you know what I don't
think dub is even going to get a plus nope cadri
over the line with Zer who takes the pass cadri
KCK off the leg of disi and then a collision in
front of the Vancouver NAD is Anderson with a
beautiful pass right on his sticking cadri you
can see cadri his stick and then he gets
return pass in front there's posil taking
Miller shov clanks it ahead to RKA pressure by
Myers riler stick tied up that allows theor to
work it through here's Greer off the way throws a
pass cross off the post RKA that close to getting
Calgary their first lead of the game Greer with
the hard pass somehow gets through Tyler Meyers
right onto the Stick of ritsa Noah hanin Rasmus
Anderson out to Martin who took a hit there by
Joshua DJ back there's B with a shot and marks
able to make the save off Brock besser open up
a little last sh two just has dub Leno
resets Anderson takes a shooting Smith
makes the save put by the score d one sneak
through and he tucks it in two one Calgary
[Applause]
now with the good play there's a big
hit from Heron everybody's looking
for a penalty now du does a nice play
getting into the middle to LY what a
s b you didn't really think the Smith
I think it might get deflected before
it gets to the goal tender and he loses
sight of it and Dylan dubet comes right
in behind you could hear the crowd Roar HTO
nice pass to backl tries a shot glove saved
by D Sim with Coleman right there pardon me
to Smith Coleman right there able to hang
on play up the near side to Nick D Simone
cross to zor rer deflected and that goes
wide R sto by the Smith got the left leg over
to make that save no traffic he'll work it in
deep press legs off the bench for Calgary
Tire Kox Coleman Hanahan Hanahan surveys
he'll cut in front tries it he scores
Hanan two play and it's 31 [Applause]
[Music] calary what a great individual effort
from Noah Hanahan let's watch this how he's
going to attack than that he's going to get
below the goal line and then come out front
just basically handing stick in front of the
goal line that's an amazing play oh you know
what Pon I think it may go off the Stick of
Pon let's see yes indeed it does go off Pon
and then off the goal tender to Smith that doesn't
take away the great individual effort from hanen
but the Smith Heron it look at front
of the empty net blames keep it onside
Coleman passive front Deni by Hughes
got to stick in the way backley here's
a chance hubo scores hubo puts
it home 4 one [Applause] [Music]
calary from the backland line starts really
with Coleman down low right here he's going
to gather that loose Puck and there's pronic
not strong enough the puck comes to bin he
spots hubero who we said had a great second
period and he can converts as the Smith goes
down he elevates quickly over the shoulder High
short side liler with the tip in t there Hanan
liler checks in here's a chance D St by Mar
hasn't been busy lately Mar forced there to
make a nice save up high off the shoulder and
the pucks play down the ice Myers puts the puck
in laer chips it behind the net racing on to
it Bel Meyers they score tipped in front by
hold Lander nice redirection top Corner
Flames lead down to two you think of DJI
good scoring chance now they work the puck
down L laery to Tyler Myers look at that
without any hesitation he sees hoglander
wandering away from the coverage that's
a really smart play by hoglander get away
from Simone perfect Target stick laid it
out there and we've got a 4-2 game so H ler
gets his fourth Flames back on the attack
cadri shoots stopped by the Smith rebound
they chop away and it winds up on the far
boards Miller passing deflected stop marks from
rebounds it off St now a go for the power play
as the ples get the P the l call B jaapani works
out on Hughes nice move here's B jaapani sto by
the Smith got the right pan up what a move by Von
to get around Hughes GT Miller on the boards BS
it to Hughes Hughes plays it across intercepted
good stick there by hubo gets it up and there's
an empty B for lindol hubo with the pass lindol
gets his fourth point tonight and that should seal
it with 152 to go so here's Hughes and there's
a real nice play right there by Jonathan hubero
intercepts that pass gets it to lyol final seconds
wind down laer one more shot off the post a save
by Mark and that'll do it Rock Solid effort first
game back off an Eastern swing for the flames